bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce sens
public la nouvelle émission de public
sénat l'émission qui donne du sens à
l'actualité l'émission qui se met au
service des citoyens alors je vous
retrouve exceptionnellement ce soir dans
le fauteuil de thomas hugues pour 1h30
d'analystes de décryptage autour de deux
débats cette concept de l'émission un
premier débat consacré à un thème
d'actualité un second débat a pour
exercer un droit de suite approfondir ou
anticiper et puis entre les deux notre
rubrique les électeurs ont la parole
vous pouvez commenter l'émission tout au
long sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag sens public
au sommaire de ce numéro de quoi eric
zemmour est il le nom alors là connu
journalistes on le connaît aujourd'hui
polémiste on ne connaîtra sans doute
demain candidats sur quels ressorts
s'appuie sa popularité jusqu'où peut-il
troubler le jeu politique et puis
surtout qu'est-ce que ses propositions
et ses provocations raconte de la france
de 2021 ce sera le thème de notre
premier débat dans les électeurs la
parole notre seconde partie nous nous
posons une question qui doit sauver nos
vieux monuments l'état où les joueurs de
lotto depuis la mise en place de la
mission patrimoine en 2010 est celle de
stéphane bern près de 527 sites
emblématiques ont reçu des subventions
ce soir nous vous emmènerons chez marcel
proust à elie congrès mais aussi au
château du neubourg en normandie enfin
que reste-t-il de la sphère benalla le
procès de l'ancien proche collaborateur
du chef de l'état s'est ouvert cette
semaine nous reviendrons sur ce que ce
scandale a révélé de l'exercice du
pouvoir sur les leçons qui en ont été
tirés ou pas et puis surtout sur les
conséquences politiques de ce qui
restera comme le premier tournant du
quinquennat mais tout de suite notre
premier débat c'est la sensation de ce
début de campagne présidentielle
eric zemmour n'est pas encore candidat
mais il ne cache plus ses ambitions
comment l'ancien éditorialiste s'est il
transformé en animal politique c'est un
sujet de cécile section
il rêvait de politique mais son échec au
concours de l'ena poussé eric zemmour
vers le journalisme dans les années 90
il devient journaliste au figaro et très
vite se fait remarquer sur les plateaux
télé pour ses qualités de débatteur et
ses prises de position comme dans cette
émission de thierry ardisson face à
clémentine autain et s'inscrit
complètement dans la vague néo réac
c'est vrai pourquoi néo ça a
complètement et ac
la productrice de l'émission propose son
nom pour un nouveau programme on n'est
pas couché en 2006 le grand public
découvre alors eric zemmour ça s'écoute
volontiers
horrifié 11 10 ports collabore ensuite à
rtl itélé comme éditorialiste marqué à
droite pour benoît daragon journalistes
médias au parisien c'est son livre le
suicide français qui va tout changer en
le polémiste se radicalise et multiplie
les débordements misogyne xénophobe et
anti musulmans nous montre dans ce
métier c'est un peu radicaliser hélas
les rédactions vont être gêné parce que
voilà une rédaction d'un grand média
doit s'afficher un neutre politiquement
très marquée politiquement ces
problématiques dans une grande réaction
quand vers tel ou qui va être petit à
petit mais à pied des mises à pied mais
aussi des condamnations par la justice
en 2019 il revient sur ses news dans
l'émission face à l'info là pour le coup
et mais presque seul sans contradiction
expliquer toute sa pensée et là c'est
plus un journaliste qu'on voit c'est
même plus un éditorialiste on voit un
homme politique qui est
donne ses idées sa vision de la france
contraint de quitter l'émission à la
demande du csa il ne s'est pas pour
autant déclarer candidat à la
présidentielle même s'il laisse planer
le doute sur ses intentions eric zemmour
la stratégie du trublion on en parle ce
soir avec mathieu soupière consultant
expert à la fondation jean jaurès
coauteur d'un livre qui vient de sortir
avec damien fleurot 2022 la flambée
populiste chez plon à vos côtés
catherine tricot directrice de la revue
regards j'accueille également le
politologue emmanuel rivière directement
les études internationales concept
politique de cantat et puis bien sûr
notre chroniqueuse laetitia krupa qui
m'accompagnera tout au long de
l'émission laetitia qui attendaient ce
débat avec d'autant plus d'impatience
qu'elle vient de publier un livre au
titre prémonitoire la tentation du clown
comment un candidat hors système va
bouleverser l'élection présidentielle
c'est chez buchet chastel pour commencer
ce débat j'ai envie de faire un tour de
table et vous demander de quoi eric
zemmour est il le nom plutôt comment
vous le qualifiez on commence avec vous
car je mathieu scolaire à partir du
moment où marine le pen effectivement a
échoué aux élections régionales le
diable s'habille en humour c'est à dire
que zemmour incarne assez bien
l'excellent l'extrême droite isation de
la société française et par ailleurs
l'élément perturbateur que tout le monde
attendait dans cette campagne puisque
même si on annonçait un duel une finale
entre maquereau et le pen ou en tout cas
même si l'opinion semble s'attendre à
cette finale là l'opinion n'en veut pas
donc l'opinion attendait un élément
perturbateur eric zemmour peut-être cet
élément perturbateur c'est un populiste
il a assurément des côtes et populiste
mais là où le populiste en appelle au
peuple et c'est le cas de marine le pen
eric zemmour en appel davantage à la
france et donc de ce point de vue là il
se situe assez bien dans la tradition de
l'extrême droite française telle qu'on
la connaît depuis dix neuvième siècle
catherine tricot comment vous le
qualifié eric zemmour and idéologues qui
veut reconstruire une pensée de droite
réactionnaire solide dire que c'est
assez loin d'être simplement un
journaliste et un trublion je pense que
c'est quelqu'un d'assez solide avec une
grosse culture politique beaucoup
d'analystes politiques
je pense qu'on connaît tous autour de la
table pour la finesse de ses analyses et
je pense que il je crois pas qu'ils
aient l'ambition des présents de la
république par contre de redonner à la
droite une structure politique je pense
que oui c'est ça son objectif et
s'oppose à marine le pen il s'oppose
aussi à la droite traditionnelle
c'est un idéologue où sa venue en
politique il serait pas candidat selon
vous si il sera peut-être candidat mais
il est candidat comme idéologues c'est
d'une certaine manière moi je trouve
qu'il fait un peu la même le même
parcours de début de campagne que jean
pierre chevènement il ya une quinzaine
d'années qui venait porter qui était
lui-même un homme politique mais qui
venaient pour bien philippe andurand
exactement et pourquoi ça se
terminera mais pour eric zemmour ce sera
la même chose je ne crois pas à la
candidature d'eric zemmour je pense
qu'elle sera comme ça de jean pierre
chevènement ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'ils n'ont pas quelque chose à dire et
qui n'ont pas qui veut pas porter un des
paroles dans cette première partie de
campagne on va y revenir emmanuel
rivière quand vous le qualifié eric
zemmour peau c'est un porte parole la
parole d'une france qui représente un
certain nombre de français qui vit le
destin de la france comme significatif
d'un déclin qui les inquiète qu'ils
envoient ce qu'il relie beaucoup aux
questions d'identité d'immigration et
qui apprécie chez eric zemmour qui porte
cette parole avec talent c'est à dire
qu'il lui donne une espèce de caution
parce que d'abord il a un talent
oratoire incontestable puis comme ces
matinées de référence historique sa
légitime en fait une parole mais
totalement débridé c'est à dire que les
thèmes de l'utilisent sont des thèmes
qui sont assez largement employé
évidemment au rassemblement national
mais également dans une partie de la
droite des républicains en revanche les
exemple qu'il cite les points de
focalisation les questions de la
question du prénom les questions très
relative à l'islam là pour le coup c'est
roue libre et ça je pense que ça séduit
une partie des français qui disent c'est
comme ça que je pense non plus lui le
dit bien c'est aussi roue libre pour
tous les revisite l'histoire on l'a vu
parfois notamment avec l'histoire du
maréchal pétain et la situation des
juifs en france laetitia krupa moi je
vais vous citer une phrase de gérald
bronner le sociologue que j'avais
rencontré longuement pour un monde en
quête zemmour c'est l'incarnation de la
panique au portugal qui va avoir lieu en
2022 c'est à dire que sur la ligne de
départ il va certainement y avoir un
très très grand nombre de candidats et
il me semble qu'effectivement il ya une
place pour un clown
alors un clown on vous au sens ce
symbole non non ça peut faire rire oui
et ça peut effrayer également il ya
aussi le clown blanc moralisateur ou les
clowns de beckett voyez donc le clown
n'est pas uniquement le nez rouge qui
fait rire les enfants évidemment eric
zemmour ressemble davantage au clown est
effrayant du joker le
blockbuster de todd phillips ils sont
nés soit que mal fini voilà et c'est
pour ça que je file la métaphore il me
semble que ce serait un petit peu trop
hâtif et 9 de faire le parallèle avec
jean pierre chevènement notamment sur la
fin de l'épopée peut-être le début ça y
ressemble mais la fin ne soyons pas
naïfs c'est l'incarnation d'une époque
aussi riggs et moorea bien compris que
l'époque était mûr et que s'il y avait
un moment c'était celui ci celui de 2022
donc est-ce qu'il va y aller ou pas en
tout cas le constat il me semblait juste
fait que le système est à bout et ça
peut être peut-être un homme qui propose
une autre solution c'est ça la fameuse
posture de l'homme providentiel à quelle
famille idéologique il appartient est ce
que le classé à droite ou l'extrême
droite je comprendre qu'ils avaient des
divergences pour vous c'est plutôt à
l'extrêmement à toi moi c'est une droite
très conservatrice réactionnaire on va
dire cette droite réactionnaire
je pousserai quand même le bouchon un
peu plus loin et en particulier en
insistant sur une singularité d'eric
zemmour que votre votre reportage tout à
l'heure le rappelait mais je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on insiste suffisamment là dessus
c'est quand même le seul candidat à
l'élection présidentielle dans notre
histoire récente et même de moyenne
durée qui se présentent en ayant été
condamné par la justice de son pays
candidats alors pardon c'est un
potentiel candidat qui a quand même été
condamné par la justice de son pays on a
des exemples d'ex président de la
république qui ont eu maille à partir
avec la justice et qui pour certains ont
été condamnés mais des candidats qui y
vont en traînant ça on se traînant sa
haut à la cheville à la cheville et on
parle de condamnations multiples est
récente et autrement dit de propos
assumer et pas n'importe quel propos
encore une fois incitation à la haine
raciale donc de ce point de vue là il me
semble qu'on peut vraiment le ranger à
l'extrême droite et j'ajoute que c'est
tout le bas c'est un des paradoxes de
zemmour
il il en appelle en permanence à
l'autorité de l'état il dénonce en
permanence le laxisme de la justice il
dénonce en permanence ces hordes
délinquants qui ne respectent pas les
lois de la république or il faut quand
même reconnaître eric zemmour lui même
ne respectent pas les lois de la
république ou en tout état de cause qu
il a été condamné à plusieurs reprises
je reviens sur ce que vous disais la
droite la droite qui l'incarnent c'est
au fond la droite légitimiste dans le
classement de daron c'est quoi c'est la
droite contre-révolutionnaires là votre
bonapartiste c'est quoi c'est la droite
vous mettez où il n'est pas dans l'excès
très conservateur s'est laissé pousser
vraiment réaxer patiemment conservateurs
ces réactionnaires c'est quand même il
veut revenir retrouver un ordre ancien
qu'un ordre perdu la france blanche
patriarcale et c'est enfin choisir c'est
ça son sa référence et c'est sur ça
qu'il qu'il joue en permanence mots ce
qui me trouble dans votre appellation
clown c'est que le clown c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui est un peu en système
et qui vient perturber le système eric
zemmour il est dans le système il n'est
pas dans le système politique
n'est pas un élu politique enfin il est
un journaliste politique qui est dans le
sérail politique depuis trente ans et ça
c'est une acceptation parce que
peut-être que vous vous sentez je ne
sais pas où vous êtes vous dans le
sérail ou pas enfin concernant votre
position personnelle mais je pense que
pour les français quand il voit eric
zemmour il ne fait pas partie du monde
politique et d'ailleurs il l'a bien
compris parce que dans toutes ses
interviews toutes ces interventions pour
le moment je suis père très attention au
verbatim qui l'emploie il répète
d'entrée je ne suis pas de ce monde
politique je n'en ai pas fait un métier
je ne suis pas un professionnel de la
politique
c'est qu'elle tourne ça perturbe aussi
l'ordre établi et zemmour ne perturbe
pas l'ordre établi les du côté je
voudrais encore une fois des des forces
puissantes et pas du tout du côté des
marginaux et en ce sens il est l'exact
opposé de coluche par exemple en 1986 à
celle inverse puisque en effet de
classer un peu
je menais la rivière si on retourne la
question à quelle france par le tilt et
il parle à la fois la france qui a voté
marine le pen et qui a voté françois
fillon en 2017 ça c'est très clair dans
les différentes enquêtes quand on teste
eric zemmour candidats ils puissent
danser électorat là et d'ailleurs quand
on fait la différence entre les
hypothèses d'intentions de vote où il
est présent et absent mais on voit bien
qui prend chez hervé bertrand comme chez
bertrand c'est bien il beltran comme
juste chez marine le pen que je suis
ouverte à un départ d un caddie prend un
peu des deux mais je ressens il
s'inscrit dans cette dans cet univers-là
avec des thématiques qui sont quand même
les thématiques obsessionnelle du
rassemblement national principalement
les migrations l'immigration l'identité
la question de du modèle d'intégration
et c'est vrai que là ils jouent sur ces
difficultés françaises à se départir
d'un modèle plus ou moins fantasmée
d'assimilation sur lequel il va pointer
un certain exemple sur les questions
économiques qui sont un peu aussi un des
moyens différencier la droite et la
gauche je sais pas si les gens là bas
beaucoup moins perçu sur ces questions
en revanche il ya bien effectivement ce
qui permet de le qualifier aussi comme
appartenant à au phénomène populiste sa
volonté de se démarquer parce que ça les
deux ingrédients le populisme et définir
le peuple qui n'en ai pas et se
démarquer des élites qui ont gouverné
jusqu'à présent et de ce point de vue là
je pense qu'il est un peu latin section
des deux et il parle plutôt aux
personnes âgées aux plus jeunes aux
hommes aux femmes mourir aujourd'hui on
y parle à tout le monde
très grande visibilité dit médiatique on
voit qu'il parle à une partie des jeunes
quand on regarde aujourd'hui les
différentes enquêtes il parle aussi aux
personnes plus âgées n'y a pas de zones
de force et surtout il n'y a pas ces
deux caractéristiques qui ont souvent
les candidats populistes de s'adresser
principalement aux catégories populaires
il fait pas des scores fenomeno chez les
ouvriers comme le faisait marine le pen
à une époque
a priori cette partie là de l'échiquier
la droite l'extrême droite les la
frontière entre les deux elle est déjà
bien occupé pour 2022 en rappel cas
marine le pen probablement nicolas
dupont aignan xavier bertrand
probablement un candidat ait l'air on
pourrait ajouter françois asselineau
jean lassalle comment eric zemmour at-il
ou peut-il réussir à se faire une place
sur ce terrain bien occupé match au
caire il ya un autre paradoxe avec eric
zemmour c'est que il percute marine le
pen par sa droite et or on sait qu'il a
lui-même considéré est dit que marine le
pen était à ses yeux une femme de gauche
donc il l'a percutée par la droite et il
est celui qui paradoxalement peut
permettre de faire la passerelle entre
l'extrême droite et la droite
républicaine il était allé parler avec
marion maréchal-le pen lors d'une
convention qui prônait précisément en
fait à à terme cette alliance là donc ça
fait partie des paradoxes de d'eric
zemmour et pour rebondir sur ce que
disait emmanuel rivière il ya
effectivement enfin dans les enquêtes
elle compte tels qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui il y a autre singularité
d'eric zemmour il y à chérif ghemmour
une même captation de catégories
populaires et de csp + c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans les intentions de
vote en tout cas dans les personnes qui
se retrouvent dans le discours d'eric
zemmour il y a les deux ce qui est très
rare françois fillon en 2017 c'était le
candidat de la bourgeoisie marine le pen
c'est aujourd'hui et depuis un moment en
fait le rassemblement social c'est le
parti des ouvriers eric zemmour arrive à
parler aux de france il a un discours
xénophobe qui séduit une partie des
catégories populaires et il a par
ailleurs un discours fait de références
historiques littéraires un discours
cultivé qui parle au lectorat du figaro
et ateliers aux centaines de milliers
d'ultra autres poulets gorille de
comparaison
réponse peut-être parce que tout le
monde en passant que sans même qu'il
soit candidat c'est ça la grande
différence d'eric zemmour il est dans
toutes les émissions politiques de cette
rentrée il est partout et il n'est pas
candidat or on ne parle pas des autres
on en parle un peu de me
il n'est pas encore une fois politique
et qu'il entre par surprise qui n'est
pas encore entré là posé un orteil par
surprise dans la campagne et que c'est à
1,1 me semble un scénario qui excite
aussi le landerneau politico-médiatique
je transcris cause qu'une méthode votre
avion pour occuper cet espace est ce
qu'on ait l'impression que zemmour il
prend acte de la droitisation d'une
partie de la politique française mais en
même temps avec une france qui
politiquement et des fêtes elle est
défaite par emmanuel macron par l'opac
emmanuel macron a fait sur cet espace
politique donc zemmour je pense qu'il
est là pour essayer de redonner du tonus
une colonne vertébrale à cette droite
qui est exactement ce que ce que tu a
rappelé m je soutiens tout à l'heure
c'est
les la bourgeoisie d'une part et un
parti au respecter les artères et une
fois la partie des catégories populaires
qui il faut s'en souvenir n'a jamais
toujours voté à gauche il ya toujours eu
une partie sur des catégories populaires
qui se retrouvent reconnu dans la droite
conservatrice et donc lui il veut
redonner un socle à ça parce que sinon
ce enfin je veux dire on n'est pas là
pour discuter ce soir de la droite
classique à la droite classique pour
l'instant bien du mal à
les maquereaux et oui si on parlait il
ya une forme de d'ambiguïté on ne sait
pas encore s'il est candidat au livre
montre des toutes ses ambitions toutes
ses intentions mais il ne s'est pas
encore déclaré il en joue même écouter
ce qu'il déclarait sur sur rtl cette
terre entière
ce n'est pas parti vite vous apprendre
qu'on ne sort de l'ambiguïté qu'à ses
dépens à qu'à son détriment et donc est
donc vous êtes en pleine d'ambiguïté bah
oui
et donc je peux faire durer sa donc
d'autant que c'est mon intérêt ça promet
j'ai continue donc de l'année ce faux
mystère mais ça lui vaut les foudres du
csa qui considère que c'est un homme
politique est plus un éditorialiste
alexandre tout ça vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi et comment se fonde
la décision la décision du csa et oui
c'est une décision du conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel qui a fait beaucoup de
bruit et elles se font sur la loi à la
loi 2
1986 qui prévoient que le temps de
parole des personnalités politiques doit
être décomptés par les médias pour
respecter un pluralisme des idées sur
les plateaux et le csa veut donc
appliquer cette loi pour eric zemmour
une décision justifiée dans un
communiqué je le cite le csa a considéré
qu avec zemmour pouvait être regardé
dorénavant autant par ses prises de
position et ses actions que par les
commentaires auxquels elle donne lieu
comme un acteur du débat politique
national
la conséquence c'est que la chaîne ces
news a été obligé de retirer eric
zemmour de l'émission face à l'info où
ils intervenaient tous les soirs pendant
une heure et forcément l'éditorialiste a
crié à la censure du csa écoutez là j'ai
toujours émis des opinions politiques
ceux qui me suivent depuis des années le
savent très bien et c'est bien mon droit
en tant que journaliste dont la carte de
presse 57 sens au soutien le rappeler
même si ça ne me rajeunit pas
garanti mais droit de d'opinion
d'expression
il n'ya il n'ya absolument en a pas le
droit de censurer mes propos et le csa
en moins que tout autre moins que toute
autre institution n'a le droit de
contrôler les opinions des gens et
encore moins des journalistes est alors
à ces accusations de censure le
président du csa roch olivier maistre a
répondu personnellement et rappelle que
tous les éditorialistes ne sont pas
soutenues par une association de
financement de campagne ni n'apparaisse
sur des affiches avec la mention
président ni ne sont pris en compte dans
les sondages c'est le cas d'eric zemmour
donc voilà après cette décision du csa
ça va être compliqué pour eric zemmour
d'avoir autant d'exposition médiatique
qu'avant c'est à dire une heure
d'antenne par jour merci alexandre est
ce qu'une méthode zemmour j'hésite leur
ont l'impression qu'il ya un triptyque
obsession provocation victimisation et
qu'à la fin c'est toujours lui qui rafle
la mise pour
le coup l'hymne seco chez notre case la
chance qu'on a indiqué tout à l'heure
c'est à dire se présenter comme victime
d'un système et se présentait comme
étant censuré évidemment
raccrochée une attention particulière et
l'envi de danie rossouw cours de cet
homme là puisqu'il représenterait le
système que l'on cocon colonies et d'où
l'intérêt je pense effectivement je
pense qu'il vit le meilleur moment de sa
période c'est à dire peut-être qu'il va
renoncer et dans ce cas là immédiatement
il retrouvera peut-être son temps
d'antenne mais il sut sera beaucoup
moins l'intérêt que vous soulignez tout
à l'heure et quand il leur faudrait
l'armure pour être candidat mais ce
serait différent on cesserait de se
précipiter sur eric zemmour à chaque
fois qu'il remue une oreille pour voir
si dans l'âme le petit mouvement du lobe
on décèle un pas supplémentaire vers la
candidature il deviendra un candidat qui
l'opposera de toutes autres questions
que celles qu'on se pose actuellement
sera-t'il où nos candidats la décision
du csa c'est un vrai ou un faux coup dur
pour l'hexagone mathieu st pierre pour
le coup c'est tu sais c'est un bon coup
d'accélérateur forcément parce que dans
la rhétorique du populiste ou du leader
d'extrême droite il ya toujours la
dénonciation du système eric zemmour et
ça va pas de lier de sa précampagne
s'est toujours posée comme une sorte de
paria alors qu'il est au coeur du
système médiatique depuis très longtemps
dos et c'est vrai mais mais mais le
populiste ou le leader d'extrême droite
jouent souvent là dessus la méthode
zemmour comme on dit là dessus sur sur
l'efficacité de la méthode zemmour elle
tient au fait que eric zemmour se situe
au centre de gravité de la société
française quand il met en avant le
déclin de la france quand il met en
avant la faillite des élites et quand il
met en avant la question identitaire qui
lie à la question migratoire qui le lie
à la question sécuritaire et là vraiment
on voit bien que sur ce triptyque là
c'est le coeur du patient français il
est trés alors pour le coup dans les
grandes enquêtes d'opinion aux moyennes
durées on voit bien que sur ces sujets
là l'opinion française et est très
homogène et très homogène et j'ajoute
que si il est un élément perturbateur
aujourd'hui c'est parce que précisément
la question identitaire migratoire
sécuritaire et celles qui assurent un
lien et même un simon assez solide entre
le les sympathisants des républicains et
les sympathisants du rassemblement
national c'est les aimants le sujet
lequel est la droite classique et
l'extrême droite se rejoignent de façon
très nette depuis quelques années il
fait complètement l'impasse sur la
question sociale parce que n'est pas
propositions pour l'emploi pour le
logement qui sont aussi
catherine tricot oui moi je ne crois pas
que la question identitaire je pense que
c'est celle qui anime les plateaux
télévision et ont d'ailleurs on va
encore en parler ce soit aussi celle que
nous participons à cela mais je ne crois
pas un seul des colons non bien sûr mais
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
tout ce buzz est en nous alimentons tous
le bruit autour d'eric zemmour et on le
positionne centralement moi je ne crois
pas que les français soient centralement
intéressés par la question de savoir
s'il faut remettre l'homme au premier
plan dans le foyer s'il faut que les
prénoms soit francisé s'il faut si on
est dans le grand remplacement tout ça
je n'y crois pas je ne dis pas que ça ne
fait pas partie d'une partie de cas une
partie de la france qui se posent cette
question là je pense que les
préoccupations des français sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus centré sur les
questions d'avenir et notamment de la
question du réchauffement climatique
ça ça me paraît être une question qui
hante absolument tout le monde pour les
générations qui viennent la question de
la façon dont ça va se répercuter sur
notre manière de vivre sur la
transformation de l'économie sur la
manière de travailler etc je pense que
vraiment c'est plus ce genre de choses
et je note par exemple que la france est
le pays dans lequel il ya le plus de
mariages mixtes donc on n'est pas dans
un pays
d'angoise à l'égard des étrangers
s'étaient donc je crois que c'est une
construit je ne dis pas ça n'existe pas
ça existe dans une partie de la droite
mais c'est une l'arti de la droite qui a
du mal à se structurer roque a permis de
faire
parce que je pense qu'eric zemmour
effectivement dans son expression
mobilise beaucoup l'idée que la france
et les français seraient alignées avec
lui on n'a pas de parti a pas de
militants gagné une campagne
d'acquisition sans parti sans militants
on le verra mais c'est quand même
compliqué et sur une partie des
thématiques en fait on constate plutôt
un reflux de la crispation identitaire
le nombre de gens qui nous disent
aujourd'hui dans nos enquêtes qui a trop
d'étrangers en france certes élevée un
baromètre sur les majorations de la
nationale on est au-delà de 40% et on
était à 65 % au moment des
moments dans les banlieues de 2005 le
baromètre annuel de la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme entre la même tendance d'une
plus grande ouverture et en plus c'est
quand on regarde les générations mais
les plus jeunes sont effectivement dans
un rapport à la question du voile un
paquet sur un rapport la question des
étrangers est différent et suit un point
important vous avez évoqué sur la
question des rapports de genre alors
pour le coup il est très décalée du
centre de gravité la population
française mot en revanche sur la
question du déclin et la question du
rejet des élites effectivement là il ya
un alignement mais il ya peut-être une
erreur de lecture de pas que de sa part
d'un certain nombre d'observateurs sur
la question de la crispation identitaire
les français sont pas plus anti
musulmans plus anti étrangers
aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'était il ya dix
ans ils sont même plutôt moins alors
y'en a un autre sur la question du genre
qui était limite c'était donald trump
aux états unis un des exemples de clown
dans le cirque politique à l'étranger y
en a eu au sens propre du terme je pense
à beppe grillo l'humoriste italiens 9 du
politique mais pour revenir à donald
trump c'est lui que vous avez choisi de
vous intéresser et peut-être de
désespoir de comparaison ou devriez à
sion pourquoi c'est pas du tout moi qui
ai comparé eric zemmour à donald trump
ce sont les troupes même d'eric zemmour
c'est à dire qu'ils ont choisi donald
trump en modèle voyez l'oncle américain
et s'y trompe pas réussi pourquoi pas
eric zemmour marine le pen apparemment a
dit à des journalistes en dehors des
micros à l'art de laure c'était quand
samedi je n'en sa rentrée politique elle
a dit j'ai dit à eric zemmour que la
théorie selon laquelle la france attend
un trust je n'y crois pas voilà donc
vous voyez bien que c'est orchestré par
le camp et mouret d'ailleurs on le voit
régulièrement dans le journal qui est un
peu son organe de presse 1 j'ai envie de
vous dire valeurs actuelles qui ne cesse
de poser cette question mais vraiment
c'est redondant si vous remontez même
sur un an c'est une question qui revient
et alors ils présentèrent exe moore
comme le trump à la française donc
cultiver voyez ce qu'il faut quand même
reconnaître à 0 eric zemmour n'a jamais
rien géré de sa vie d'une certaine façon
alors que donald trump et thème gérer
des affaires un empire c'était un petit
peu différent même fortune moto pas du
tout non mais ils n'ont rien à voir
enfin en termes d'épaisseur et je ne
parle pas que du physique et vous avez
bien ses accessoires et pas du tout
parce que je suis désolé mais le
charisme ça passe aussi par l'image que
l'on donne de soi immédiate donc il ya
vraiment pas l'épaisseur de donald trump
mais il en est un défenseur vraiment
fervent et ses constants j'ai retrouvé
ce qu'il avait dit sur son plateau donc
de ces news le 6 janvier on était juste
quelques heures avant l'assaut du
capitole par les fans de donald trump
vous savez il y va carrément je pense
que le tropisme et le populisme en
général rendre reste quand même le
mouvement de l'avenir alors il y va mais
vraiment il prend pas de gants il
explique qu'au grand remplacement va
s'ajouter le grand déclassement donc là
c'est la jambe social à vous voyez il ya
bien sûr qu'ils jouent sur la sécurité
mais il parle quand même aux classes
populaires et il dit carrément il faudra
simplement qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui
comme trump avec tous ses défauts lève
le drapeau et accepte de combattre pour
ça on est en janvier mathieu ça c'est
vraiment clairement une entrée en
candidature oui il parle pour lui et
donc bien sûr qu'on ce parallèle je
vraiment je mets mon billet là sur la
table on va la voir s'il rentre en
campagne dès le départ ça vous parle
monsieur soupière
oui enfin en tout cas il ya quelques
parallèles qu'on peut faire il est
évident que zemmour et trump ont en
partage vous le disiez tout à l'heure la
xénophobie d'abord et la misogynie par
ailleurs et il était très étonnant de
constater qu aux etats-unis + + trump
faisait de sortie misogyne voire
ouvertement sexistes et grossièrement
sexistes plus il montait dans les
sondages alors là où je vous rejoins
ccoc heureusement en france a priori
touchons du bois on ne se situe pas du
tout dans le même contexte donc ça ils
l'ont clairement en partage
et par ailleurs il cherche à s'adresser
l'un et l'autre tels que trump le
faisait il ya quelques années à
l'électorat alors zemmour dire est
probalement les français de souche faso
qui ont les bons prénom etc mais on voit
bien qu'ils cherchent à à s'adresser à
peu près à la même population ensuite il
ya un vrai une vraie distinction une
vraie différence vous le disiez tout à
l'heure trump c'est vraiment le
populisme populaire lao et il y a dans
le populisme qui a toujours dans le
populisme une dimension anti
intellectualiste anti élites
intellectuelles aussi ce que n'est pas
du tout et l'examen par définition les
jeux pardon je termine là dessus eric
zemmour quand même pour pour l'écho que
que son discours rencontre dans
l'opinion et celui qui à la télévision
réalise les meilleures audiences et il
est celui qui parmi tous les essayistes
écrase le box office et je crois que
j'en passe et ce matin la fnac c'était
l'émeute c'était le jour de sortie de
son livre c'était l'émeute et militer de
gens peut-être des ventes en même d'être
en stock absolument 4 entre cokéfaction
les états unis avec trump l'italie avec
beppe grillo ça date déjà de quelques
années mais on pourrait ajouter aussi
quelques leaders britanniques qui au
moment du break site qu'est ce que ça
raconte te détendre que se trouvent les
plus vieilles démocraties du monde abbas
est certain que ça montre que la
destruction et qu'il n'y a pas de
recomposition au corps mais ce que je
pense beppe grillo par exemple n'a rien
reconstruit c'est même complètement un
délitement qu'il a contribué à accélérer
en italie par contrainte il a réussi à
faire la jonction entre le tea party qui
était vraiment le tea party les parties
les plus radicales des évangélistes et c
est le parti républicain et il a
repositionné le parti républicain à la
force du poignet sur cet axe là et dans
ce sens je ne sais pas ce que fera eric
zemmour mais en effet le travail d'eric
zemmour c'est un travail de
recomposition de recomposition de la
droite sur une frange conclura erronée
cette façon de regarder l'histoire de
trump parce que ce n'est pas trop
inquiet à ceux construits cela c'est
rome c'est le symptôme de ce qui existe
déjà c'est à dire que sur le terrain les
républicains se sont rendus compte du
succès de donald trump auprès des
américains et donc ça a donné
effectivement ce repositionnement du
parti mais c'est le terrain c'est là
eric dit invisible amérique que personne
ne voyait qui s'est exprimée dans les
urnes quand elle a décidé d'élire donald
trump qui étaient là et qui était vive
il fait un temps les incarner
s'en sont saisis ces points les tea
partiers les évangélistes etc se sont
saisis de donald trump et met donc
peut-être qu'il est moins idéologue
construit et que eric zemmour mais le
périmètre que cela dessine à mon avis
est à peu près équivalent dans les deux
cas alors jusqu'où grimpera eric zemmour
est ce qu'on est pour reprendre la
comparaison que faisait catherine tricot
tout à l'heure dans une bulle sondagière
on explique qu'un c'est le phénomène
jean pierre chevènement qui est à peu
près 12 % à l'automne 2001 et qui finit
à 5,34 dans les urnes ou est-ce qu'on
est sur un socle et avec une bonne
campagne on peut imaginer un effet
mélenchon pour reprendre un autre
exemple de quelqu'un qui avait quasiment
doubler la mise le temps d'une campagne
électorale pour être immédiatement
décevant je n'ai commencé par dire qu on
a zéro exemple en france sur une
présidentielle d'un candidat extra
politique comme vous le qualifiez qui
effectivement va à un moment franchir le
cap et dire que je déclare
officiellement ma candidature est rentré
et le coluche les modèles matheron
manuel sera politique il avait 600
militants et emilie la thur
et puis ensuite il a dit qu'il n'était
plus candidat et on a bien vu que le
portrait était était pas le même ne
serait ce que parce que coluche était
sympathique à un grand nombre de
français ce qui est pas tout à fait le
cas
les enquêtes d'opinion c'est pas tout à
fait les traits d'image de ris de veau
donc oui et là on est sur un niveau
entre 7 et 10 selon mes confrères qui
est de fait singulier par rapport à un
candidat ça veut dire singulier
singulier c'est à dire que quoi
transformer une notoriété une estime par
rapport à samedi mais en immédiatement
espèce de potentiel électoral c'est
effectivement à ce niveau là c'est bien
emmanuel macron en effet quelque chose à
ses comparables
sauf qu'à la même foi qui était plus bas
de quinze lits dans un espace qui était
aussi assez saturés puisque mais bayrou
qui était également également tester
donc voilà maintenant le suspense est
ouvert parce que quand ils changent de
statut
il va changer dans le regard des
français et puis d'autres questions vont
se poser sera plus la question est il
candidat mais la question peut-il être
posées veut-il être président et puis à
la question intermédiaires qui est est
ce que je compte sur lui pour me
débarrasser de tel ou tel c'est là après
où toutes les comparaisons sont
intéressantes par rapport aux analyses
et sociétés occidentales et où il ya
quelque chose qui a ensuite bien devient
une règle c'est que le système politique
à deux tours à la française il est à peu
près unique donc il fournit pas du tout
les mêmes les mêmes mécanismes mais ce
souk r à qui profitent ces moments est
ce qu'au fond c'est pas tout bénéfice
pour emmanuel macron et c'est une
machine à faire perdre et la droite et
l'extrême droite alors encore une fois
on ne sait pas s'il est candidat on ne
sait pas si ça comprend les prothèses
qu'il ne sait pas si sa candidature
permettra de créer une dynamique et la
question de savoir au détriment de qui
ce fait cette dynamique n'est pas une
question simple ce qui est sûr c'est que
s'il entrait en campagne donc s'il avait
les 500 signatures pour être candidat ce
qui n'est pas non plus garanti mais s'il
entrait en campagne il est très probable
qu'il ferait une bulle et le système et
même s'il devait finir comme ce pauvre
jean pierre chevènement à 5% à la fin
après avoir espéré être à 10 ou être à
15 n'oublions pas que chevènement plus
taubira que d'autres et c'est ça fait
que lionel jospin qui devait être
président n'est même pas au deuxième
tour et que sa qualification pour le
second tour et à 17% absolument mais on
peut du coup imaginer que à la faveur du
nombre de candidatures qui aujourd'hui
en train de s'enregistrer que l'élection
de 2022 ressemble bien davantage qu'à
celle de 2017 as de 2002 où un mélange
l'automobile de 2016 compétition
autrement il fait plus de mal à la
droite ou à l'exécutif aujourd'hui alors
à l'extrême droite ils attaquent alors
alors très sincèrement les deux îles
pardon mais les deux hypothèses sont
tout à fait possible c'est à dire que
eric zemmour peut empêcher marine le pen
d'être au deuxième tour et haute de ce
que vous entendez dans son discours
c'est plus c'est comme ça que je que je
est ce que vous pensez qu'il concentre
ses tirs aujourd'hui sur l'extrême
droite et sur la droite et alors il
concentre clairement c'est alors il
concentre clairement seti a
implicitement sur emmanuel macron dont
il dénonce la politique mais il
concentre par tactique évidemment ces
tirs également sur marine le pen pour
justifier d'être le candidat de
substitution est par ailleurs sa
présence des porte le débat vers le
centre de gravité du mal à se déporter
vers l'extrême droite il peut tout à
fait empêcher marine le pen d'être au
deuxième tour il peut aussi servir de
réserve de voix pour marine le pen dans
l'hypothèse où elle serait au deuxième
tour et et de la même manière il peut
tout à fait aussi un réservoir de voix
pour le candidat des républicains si le
candidat des républicains qui sort du
chapeau se placent sur une ligne très
très sarkozyste pour revenir au scrutin
de 2007 et c'est sans doute pour cette
raison que marine le pen ne l'attaquent
pas ou peu écouter la
réponse jeunes et ce serait encore une
fois pas d'adversaire dans le camp de
ceux qui croient en la france donc ça
serait un grand clivage ceux qui croient
en la france et ceux qui n'y croient
plus je pense que eric zemmour fait
partie de ceux qui croient en la france
nous avons des divergences c'est sûr
mais je pense qu'on gagne dans l'union
et pas dans la division donc je ne le
traiterait jamais comme un adversaire le
riviera qui fait le plus de mal résume
aujourd'hui et fait du mal à ses
concurrents sur le même espace politique
c'est vraiment ce que ce que décrivait
mathieu laclé des élections
présidentielles en france à deux tours
c'est maîtriser l'offre autour de soi
dégager autant que ce faire se peut le
terrain parce qu'il faut se qualifier au
second tour et donc là il fait elle fait
il fait du mal où il ferait du mal à
marine le pen
xavier bertrand parce que finalement il
peut y avoir un doute sur le fait que
cette famille là où cela se qualifient
au second tour et du coup ça explique
aussi les attitudes puis par ailleurs le
charme du système français c'est
contrairement aux états unis là où trump
veut dire à propos de hillary clinton
enfermés là enfermé là enfermé là ça
finit par porter dans la présidentielle
française celui qui attaque n'est pas
forcément le bénéficiaire des attaques
et d'ailleurs ce n'est même pas sûr que
celui qui est attaquée qui insultent et
qui est mis en cause soient
véritablement esquinté ça dépend qui
l'attaquent peut-être un tricot au loin
ils attaquent l'extrême droite la droite
et il ya une forme de paradoxe parce que
en même temps sac droitiste
considérablement le débat lancé quand
j'allais vous dire c'est que moi je
pense qu'en fait ça moi mon intuition
c'est que ça sert marine le pen c'est à
dire qu en fait d'une parcelle arts au
centre vers que le paradoxe que don par
les matchs ou caceres qu' il est plus à
droite que marine le pen est en même
temps il fait un pont avec la droite
mais d'une certaine manière elle peut
venir en disant moi j'attaque personne
moi je rassemble je ne suis pas clivante
lui il a un petit peu excessif voilà il
a un petit peu excessif il va trop fort
moi je suis une femme raisonnable et je
veux rassembler tous les patriotes donc
celle là c'est la pause en d'une part
salah lui cela sort du corner d'extrême
droite ça la pose en rassembleuse moi je
pense que en plus il a challenge une
certaine manière moi je pense je sais
pour nous ce n'est pas l'objet dès
aujourd'hui mais je trouve que le
discours qu'elle a fait notre foi qui la
forme qui l'a obligé à reformuler son
discours en paca devant toutes ces idées
autour du thème des libertés c'est
exactement les idées d'avancé que deux
en ligne de mire en subliminal c'est
toujours les immigrés qui sont attaqués
par marine le pen mais elle le fait
maintenant au nom des libertés c'est à
dire qu'elles arrivent ils la force
d'une certaine manière à reformuler son
projet et elle leur formule d'une façon
beaucoup plus globale et plus ample que
zemmour qui va droit devant les femmes
faut pas qu'elle fasse du foot les
enfants pour pâques qui s'appelle kevin
etc et c'est quoi alors marine le pen
plus rassembleuse est ce que eric
zemmour s'il veut continuer va devoir
changer de posture lui aussi est ce qui
va doit être plus rassembler aujourd'hui
les un peu imprécateur a sonné le glas
être et à désigner des cibles est-ce
qu'il peut devenir un fait des plus
fédérateur et si oui ce qui perd pas de
sa valeur
bannon
fine laetitia tient ici bien sûr qu'à un
moment ça va être un peu compliqué de
vraiment vu qu'un président de la
république soit aussi plus consensuelles
dans le pin galant après on peut être
dans un pays qu à ce point fragilisée
mais c'est là où moi j'ai un doute parce
que quand on regarde les sociétés
occidentales il ya une france invisible
comme il ya d'ailleurs une allemagne
invisible dont on parle peu qu'ils sont
des pôles très stabilisateur qui ne sont
plus tôt dans la recherche de compromis
plutôt dans la recherche du consensus
qui n'ont pas envie d' aventure
exagérée qui sont plutôt révulsés et qui
représente une partie de l'électorat et
c'est aussi quelque chose qu'il faut
savoir voir ces cas là valent populistes
en europe elle a atteint ses limites
dans beaucoup d'endroits dans beaucoup
d'endroits pas partout et la france est
un peu intermédiaire de ce point de vue
là entre certains pays méditerranéens et
puis les pays les démocraties du nord de
l'europe battu socke et anne-marie de
confirmer devant marine le pen veut
devenir présidente de la république donc
elle sait
notabilisé il n'est pas dit qu'eric
zemmour qui va être manifestement
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
soit être président de la république on
fait souvent le parallèle entre eric
zemmour et le père le pnf et le père le
pen le père le pen pendant très
longtemps n'a pas cherché à être
président de la république donc le style
le style d'eric zemmour pourrait tout à
fait ressembler aux cils de le pen père
ce débat touche à sa fin juste une
question pour chacun il va jusqu'au bout
il va pas oui
lévis un meilleur bien sûr maintenant je
pense qu'il va en profiter jusqu'au bout
en tout cas fait son tricot je pense je
pense qu'il se croit un destin politique
pas celui d'être président mais celui
d'avoir de jouer un rôle et donc il ira
le plus loin possible je permets de ce
soutien il n'est pas le seul à en
décider il faut des souhaits des
signatures pour être candidat il n'est
pas sûr qu'ils y parviennent bien c'est
la fin de ce premier débat de sangsues
public donc consacré au phénomène de la
rentrée politique le phénomène zemmour
merci à tous d'y avoir participé
matthieu soupière je rappelle votre
livre un 2002 la flambée populiste chez
plon merci catherine tricot merci madame
rivière